hey youtubers its charlie happy holidays
hopefully you've had a chance to see
Star Wars by now this is gonna be my Q&A
video it will be spoilery so just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the movie yet so much awesome stuff to
talk about so let's get to it
she know because asks who would you say
your favorite villain in the movie is so
far I would definitely say kylo Ren just
because he's like a more complex version
of Anakin you get the sense that he
still has a long way to go before he's
completely fallen to the dark side even
though he thinks that he's completely
there you get this definite sense that
he could fly apart at any moment in fact
Adam driver was actually kind of poking
fun at his lightsaber just a little bit
like you get the sense that his
lightsaber could blow up at any minute
it's completely unstable
just like kylo ren's personality rewind
to the original trilogy just imagine
what it would have been like seeing the
movie from Vader's perspective we're
gonna get a chance to see a version of
that now obviously there are a lot of
other main characters that the movies
perspectives gonna be told from like
Rey's character probably the next
biggest protagonist her and kylo Ren
so the trilogy is gonna be fairly
balanced between the two of them but you
just you get a much deeper dive into
what's going on inside his head space
than you ever did with Vader next
question uncle Jerry asks can someone
explain why Luke has a metal hand since
at the end of empire he has a real
looking prosthetic hand
I think JJ Abrams just wanted it to feel
more tactile like I think if they'd gone
with a human looking hand it would have
been harder to tell that he had a fake
hand if you hadn't watched the movies
before and there are a lot of people
that are seeing Star Wars for the first
time you also get the sense when you see
that metal hand that some real big
has gone down like maybe something
stripped away all the parts that we're
covering it so it's just another way to
show the passage of time like a bunch of
stuff has happened that we haven't seen
we're just led to believe that has
gone down I may have already mentioned
it but it's the same deal with c-3po s
red arm like is just meant to show the
passage of time like seeing new scars on
people that you haven't seen in a while
next questions xmind asks is bb-8 a girl
or a guy i thought she was a girl but it
interviews John boyega said that she's a
guy so a lot of people are confused
about this now obviously a droid does
not have gender it just has gender in
the way you describe it like you use
male pronouns or female pronouns that's
what everyone's talking about originally
JJ Abrams pitched the idea of having a
female gender dry
like one that felt like it had female
personality but but I think once they
started making it it started to bleed
away a little bit and for whatever
reason I haven't really heard it
explained in great detail the characters
in the movie speak to it using male
pronouns so the characters in the movie
itself like Poe Dameron ray
they gender it male so maybe it's just
something that happened on set whenever
they were filming and JJ Abrams decided
not to change it next question mark asks
anyone think that Ray could be Luke's
daughter yeah definitely a lot of people
think that there are a couple clear
choices depending on you know what you
think JJ Abrams intentions were he did
this interview with fellow screenwriter
producer Simon Kinberg so I'm just gonna
play this clip it's all about the
simplicity of the narrative you know one
of the things it was really important I
know for us in this movie was was very
purposely going backwards to go forwards
and to embrace like literally a
structure finding a character in the
desert ending with a trench run do
something it felt very much a very
purposeful step backwards in order to
tell a brand new story with brand new
characters and and clarity of story was
really important there's so many movies
some of which I find wildly entertaining
and love but that have very confusing
plot lines and I you know I kind of love
those things but this one I knew
couldn't be that and I inspired by this
opportunity to do this movie about
working with you and this amazing crew I
tried to stretch a little bit and and
and apply different well it was a
different again it was a different
master to serve and knowing that Star
Wars is kids movie without being a kids
movie I didn't want it to be too
convoluted so a lot of it was like about
clarity just visual clarity and knowing
where you were going knowing that
Starkiller base was always off to the
right knowing that you know the lines of
action and making sure that things felt
consistent so sometimes I'd show up on
set you know and I'd have an intention
and then I'd realized that it wasn't
quite working for what this movie
required so basically what he's saying
there is is that he tried to make the
movie easy to follow you like a movie
for children that is watched by adults
so given that I don't think there's any
trickery that's going on I think that
she's probably gonna
being Luke's daughter but he also talked
about leaving certain things open-ended
for future filmmakers to deal with so
like if Rian Johnson wants to go in a
different direction they probably let
that option open
now obviously the Lucasfilm story group
controls everything from above so
they've probably already settled on who
they want Rey's parents to be the real
question is is why did Luke decide to
have a child and who was her mother
that's probably gonna be the bigger
question and you know why is she not
around it's kind of funny because some
of my original theories were EU heavy
after I saw the movie the first time I
had to go see it again and then read
some of the interviews that JJ Abrams
was doing and I was like oh he really
wanted to make it easy to follow so okay
very clearly overthinking this
probably gonna be Luke Skywalker next
question CJ Neff asks Rey was totally my
favorite but my question is who is
Captain phasma
she liked the new Jango fed to the
series or she just a captain that keeps
the troopers in line well she's actually
a very interesting character just not
one that we explored in this movie they
did say she's gonna be bigger in Episode
eight one of the most interesting things
about phasma is that she has a name she
doesn't go by a designation and like
finn did so usually what happens is when
they cast actors for roles that are kind
of mysterious like this the actor still
has to develop a character based on
something so Gwendoline Christie
probably created a lot of her backstory
in her mind when she went into it but in
the most literal of terms we'll probably
just see more scenes with her in
present-day during the movies we'll
probably learn about her backstory in
novels that's like you know perfect
territory for novels to explore but even
if you haven't read any of the EU novels
just think about the role of women in
the Empire like the emperor was
notoriously racist and notoriously
sexist so to be a woman of authority in
the Empire meant that you had to work
twice as hard as everyone else so just
think about how much of a badass phasma
has to be to Riots the rank of captain
and sound like she hasn't been
conditioned like it doesn't seem like
she's gone through the imperial
conditioning that all the stormtroopers
have but from a story perspective she's
kind of a blank slate for future
directors to mess around with like
they're gonna have a lot of fun with her
in episode 8 and episode 9 hopefully
she'll make it to episode 9 the next
question North Pole asks my big question
at the end what happened to Captain
phasma
so Captain phasma general Hux kylo Ren
they all made it off the planet at the
end the it's just you know one of the
conceits of trying to move the story
along without being able to show every
single thing
is like watching the ships travel
through hyperspace it almost seems like
it takes no time at all to get different
places in the galaxy it's just because
they want to speed the plot along it's
like yeah we know we're traveling there
so let's just get there so fast MA
Huck's kylo Ren all the most important
characters made it off the planet in
time next question and this is a big one
willis asks question going in who the
eff is the first order a question coming
out who the eff is the first order so we
actually do know quite a bit but the
problem is that you had to have read
some of the expanded material so here's
what's going on in the galaxy the Empire
Falls after the battle of jakku that was
like one of the last big battles between
the rebellion in the empire the
rebellion becomes the new republic which
then you know kind of goes on to
stagnate a little bit a lot of
infighting deciding what they should be
doing while that's going on the remnants
of the empire collects in the outer rim
and decide to form the first order so
general Leia sees this happening and
tells the New Republic look the Empire
is just turning into something different
we need to pay attention to this we need
to deal with it but the New Republic
Senate kind of descended into internal
politicking and bickering and really too
started spinning its wheels so Leia is
like look let me take a small force and
go deal with this but we need support so
they kind of addressed this during the
movie where general Hux calls out the
New Republic for supporting the
resistance and it kind of calls them out
as being like terrorists so the
resistance as you see it in the movie is
like a small splinter cell of the New
Republic that's being funded secretly by
the New Republic and that's one of the
reasons why you don't see why wings or
bee wings or any other types of ships
because the resistance is way smaller
than the original rebellion the original
rebellion is what became the New
Republic which has now been destroyed
thanks question though quagmire asks is
JJ Abrams coming back for the sequels
well he's coming back as producer but
person that's writing episode 8 in
episode 9 is ryan johnson he's directing
episode 8 and then the person that
directed Jurassic world is directing
episode 9 so different people for
episode 8 at night but Abrams is still
coming back as creative consultants next
question though Oscar asks I thought
that Vader destroyed Anakin's lightsaber
in episode 5 well it actually it fell
down one of the shoots with Luke's hand
they actually deal with it in some of
the expanding universe comics and in the
dark end
fire comic technically it's not canon
anymore so Maz Kanata will probably have
some crazy explanation in episode 8 how
she found it but what happened is you
know Luke falls down the shaft and he
gets like shunted out at the Millennium
Falcon picks him up well his hand and
the lightsaber just went down different
shoots so presumably some work crew that
was cleaning some of those shoots out
just found it in it you know passed
hands and a bunch of smugglers and then
eventually found its way to Maz Kanata
but in case there's any confusion the
lightsaber that Rey is using is the
lightsaber that was given to Luke by
obi-wan Kenobi that originally belonged
to Anakin Skywalker the one that Anakin
Skywalker built first before he became
Darth Vader and constructed a new red
lightsaber next question another big one
Robo asks is Finn going to be a Jedi or
what I think this is one of those
questions that they don't necessarily
want to answer or maybe haven't figured
out but as he's presented in this movie
it seems like they just want him to seem
like someone who's very noble like Han
Solo someone who could pick up a
lightsaber but maybe not someone who's
destined to be the same type of Jedi
that Rey is really I think they left it
open-ended so that they can change their
minds later if they want like if they
want the character to be like Leia and
be presented with that choice where it's
like yeah your force sensitive but you
have to choose the Jedi path if you want
to hone those skills just speaking from
a real-world example everybody that John
boyega has been running into has been
calling him a Jedi so I think that even
celebrities in Hollywood like mace windu
himself samuel l.jackson called him a
jedi so i think everyone wants Finn to
be a Jedi and I don't think there's
anything right now saying that he will
never become a Jedi at least not
absolutely next question s-slow asks why
the F would you only use a single shield
for such a huge base that can easily be
disabled as well like WTF where's the
logic in that so I picked this question
Justin is an example for JJ Abrams
saying that he wanted to make the plot
super easy to follow just because so
many little children were going I mean
it's it's a movie made for children but
enjoyed by adults so if you're wondering
why the movie didn't see more complex or
like the narrative didn't see more
convoluted it's just that he wanted this
movie in particular to be easy to follow
because it's all about showing the
fandom that they have respect for the
material and they're gonna do something
good and that it is a good movie I'd
still say my favorite is Empire because
it's a smaller character based movie but
there were so many things that they had
accomplished with Episode seven that I
feel like they hit all the bases they
did what they needed to do so now we can
get really excited for Ryan Johnson to
do something crazy with episode eight or
you know Episode nine to turn into
something really wild I am so excited to
see some pictures come from the set of
episode and I can't wait to see material
start coming in the next couple months
but congratulations to the giveaway
winner jacob Karuna you went to IMAX
gift certificates just be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I get your contact info and
I'll just I'll keep doing Star Wars
giveaways as I do Star Wars bonus videos
so no worrys plenty more Star Wars
giveaways coming my next Star Wars video
is probably going to be like a bonus
video for some of the characters let me
know who you want me to do first you
want me to do like a rey video or do you
want me to do kylo ren like one of those
two those are my two favorites to come
out of the movie while you guys wait for
my next video to post I did a big Easter
egg video for all the cameos in the
movies ton of Game of Thrones actors you
can click here to learn all about that
and you can click here for my Game of
Thrones dance of the Dragons trailer
video thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you